hello
everyone today i will talk about
dynamic influence in probabilistic
graphic models
this is joint work with women xiaomi and
eton
but first let me define the graphical
model
given graph with the set of vertices
and the e is the set ace suppose each
vertex
is a random variable that takes its
value from the finite domain q
and suppose each h is a constraint
defined on its variables for each
variable we
we give it a wave function v v the
function maps
the assignment of way to a real number
for its constraint e we give it a width
function
ve the function marks
the assignments of all variables in this
constraint
to a real number now for each
configuration
sigma in q to the v where a
configuration is
an assignment of all random variables
the width of sigma is e to the sum of
all the read functions power
now we can use variables constraints
domain
and weight functions to specify a
graphic model
the graphical model defines a gibbs
distribution mu
such that the probability of its
configuration
is proportional to its weight
here is an example of graphic model
given a graph t a proper color of
z is a coloring of the vertices with
colors
from 1 to q such that any two vertices
of our eggs
have different colors for example
the left picture gives a proper three
coloring
where the red wine is not a proper
coloring
the proper q color model defines the
uniform distribution mu
over all proper curcumins of g
one can verify that this is a
class of graphical models because if the
width functions
are set as this formula then
the gibbs distribution of the graphical
model
is exactly the uniform distribution mu
the graphic model is very important in
many research
areas one of the most important
computational
tasks for graphic model is to estimate
the distribution of a vector of random
variables
this problem is very motivated and also
well studied
given a graphical model instance there
are three kinds of probabilistic
influence
problem including the marginal influence
the posterior influence and the maximum
of posterior impedance
there are different measures for
probabilistic
inference
in all these methods mcmc sampling
is the most widely applicable
given a graphical model i the sampling
algorithm
those random samples branch gibbs
distribution
thus given high independent samples x
from mu i such that the total virus
distance
between x and mu i is bounded
by epsilon i one can estimate
the target probabilities that i
from these samples the needed number of
samples
and i depends on the useless i and
the desired quality of estimate
similar for the error of this sample
usually the title probabilities are
simply estimated
by counting the frequency of the samples
that satisfy certain properties
nowadays the big data proposes
new challenges for the inverse methods
the graphic models from big data you
know how huge size
moreover these models are updated
frequently
though the difference between the models
before and after
an update is uranus more
for these models running the whole
influence
algorithm for each update is two time
course
for example if the mcmc sampling is used
for each update the running time is big
omega of the product
of an i and the size of we however
the size of way can be used not just
several
buildings and an eye can be used not
several feelings
another example is the practical
algorithms
for learning graphic models such as the
constructive divergence
algorithm for learning the restricted
voicemail machine
in this argument the optimal model i
star
is obtained by updating the parameters
of the graphical models iteratively
which generates a sequence of graph
models
with the goal that the fellow graph
model
is a good approximation of ice data
to obtain the next graph model the
gradient
is calculated by performing the
probabilistic inference
in the green graphic model
in these algorithms run the four
inference algorithm
for each update is two time cost
thus in this paper we consider the
dynamic
influence problem given a graphic model
i
if is the target probability vector
and this has high b is estimator
in dynamic influence we'll know the
graph model itself
can change dynamically with time
specifically
we can add and delete the variables and
constraints
and change the width functions the goal
is to estimate the target probability
vector that i prime
the main question in this work is that
can we modify the estimator set height
high to the new estimator
that heart at prime with small
incremental cost
such that that heart eye prime is a
reasonable estimator
the dynamic influence problem is
formulated in
this single box the input is the
original
instance i the original is meter third
hard high and the update
in instance i prime the output should be
a new estimator of
the updated graphical model to
accelerate the influence algorithm
the extruded structure resided in
memories or not
once the instance is updated the data
structure should also be updated
in this talk we'll show all the updates
are generated by an offline adversary
the update is independent with the
randomness used by the algorithm
moreover we also assume that the
difference between iodine prime
is bounded otherwise there is no faster
dynamic algorithm than static inference
here the difference between the instance
is defined of this formula which is the
sum
of the symmetric difference of the
vertex
set the symmetric difference of the
asset
and the one norm of the difference
between the width functions
the main confusion of this work is a new
algorithm
that solves dynamic influence problem
efficiently
for broader class of graph models rx
training is fast
we prove that if the two instances our
bound polylogarithmic a maximum degree
and satisfy the
top bridge challengement condition the
expected running time
is bounded by the sum of nine prime and
the size of wheat prime actually
for most such instances the only
applicable state influence algorithm
is mcmc sampling thus the expected
running time
is no less than the product of night
prime
and the size of v prime
therefore our dynamic auxin achieves
a significant speed up
our dynamic influence algorithm is based
on
dynamic sampling the extra data
structure
stores the samples from the current
instance once the instance is updated
the inference algorithm first updates
the samples and then updates the
estimator based on
these samples thus
to solve the dynamics problem we first
solve the dynamic sampling problem
suppose we have a graphic model i and we
also have a random sample x
that follows precisely the gibbs
distribution
from this graphic model in f prime
with the updated instance the main
question is
that can we modify the sample x
to a new sample x prime with small
incremental cost
such that x prime follows precisely
the gibbs distribution of the update
graphic model
this problem was partially solved by
dynamic rejection sampling
the agreement is vast but limited to
soft constraint
and one set update
in this paper we propose a new algorithm
namely the dynamic gibbs sampling
the algorithm maintains an extra data
structure
for the marketing of the current
instance
once the instance is updated the data
structure is also
updated comparing to
the dynamic rejection sampling our new
algorithm
is more flexible it's applicable to
hard constraint and universal update
of the weight functions moreover it
achieves
almost the same regions as static
sampling
for typical graphical models
the main idea of dynamic gives sampling
is constructing the chain line prime
by modifying the chain on i slightly and
efficiently
we define a coupling of the chains x t
and y t where t is from zero to
infinity such that x t and y
are similar and thin yt can be obtained
by modifying xt slightly
we use efficient efficient dynamic data
structure
to store the markov chain such that the
modification can be
realized efficiently
concretely given the change x t and i
and y t are i prime if i and type prime
are similar then we can initialize the
chains
with similar initial states x 0
and y 0. because x 0 and y 0
are similar the chains can be updated
with similar delta x 0 and delta y 0
thus x 1 and y 1 are also similar
iteratively we have all x i and y i
are similar and delta x i and delta y
i are also similar
thus y can be obtained by modifying x
height slightly and the delta y high can
be obtained
by modifying delta xr slightly
overall our dynamic influence algorithm
includes three steps firstly we perform
the dynamic gibbs sampling algorithm to
obtain
unknown samples such that the total
variance distance
is normal the epsilon i
secondly we adjust the number of samples
and the area of its sample at last
we calculate the new estimator based on
these samples
the dynamic give sampling consists of
four subroutines
the first one is the subroutine for
width function
update the second one is the supporting
for
adding variables the third one is the
supporting for
constraint update and the last one the
subroutine for deleting variables
the subroutines for width function
update and
constraint update are the most technical
the following is concrete on the
subroutine for constraint
update
firstly let me explain what is the gibbs
sampling at first
given an instance i and gamma ray i
denote the neighbor's 3 in the graph
behind
for each age you weigh in e and v u a
denote the set of
all possible configurations of gamma
wave i
that differ only at u one can verify
that the marginal distribution of mu
i and we conditional and sigma is of
this formula and the distribution can be
calculated
based on the local information of v and
gamma way high
define the influence matrix of this
formula
the dublish shallow span condition
requires that
the maximum sum of the rows of
the influence matrix expanded by
one various data where data is a
positive constant
the gibbs sampling algorithm is
performed
as follows at the beginning pick an
initial state
arbitrarily in the following for each
step
pick our text vt from free uniformly
at random the value of this vertex
is drawn from the marginal distribution
mu
v t i conditional on the current
assignments of gamma with ti
for other vertices the values are
unchanged
the mixed time of a markov chain is
the number of steps needed to achieve a
given total various distance
though to keep something simple it can
be proved that
if the instance satisfies the dodge
charlesman condition
then the chain of keep sampling is fast
mixing
thus it's easy to obtain the following
observation the markov chain of gibbs
sampling
can be recovered from x0 and the
execution log
which only records vt and xt
for each step
therefore the dynamic give sampling for
constraint
update can be realized by updating the
initial state and the exclusion log of
the current instance to that of the new
instance
note that the mixing time of the current
instance
may be different from that of the new
instance
thus the dynamic game sampling algorithm
first update the value of vt
in each step and then adjust the length
of the execution log
the value update subroutine is the core
of
the algorithm in the following let me
explain
this subroutine
a tour used is the coupling of
distributions
going to distributions mu and u over
omega
the coupling of mu and nu is a joint
distribution
of x and y such that the marginal
distribution of
x is mu and the marginal distribution of
y
is mu the optimal coupling of
mu and mu is a coupling that contains
the maximal probability
of that x and y are equal
thus going to instance that only the
constraints
are different one can define a coupling
of
the chains of gibbs sampling on these
two instances
net x t varies from zero to
infinity with chain on i and y t
is chained on f prime initially
x 0 and y 0 are equal
in the following for each step pick a
vertex vt
from v uniformly at random the value of
all other vertices are unchanged
where x t v t and y t v t
are assigned according to two different
different cases if gamma v t i
and gamma v t i prime are equal
then x t t and y t v t
are sampled from the optimal coupling of
these two marginal distributions
otherwise they are sampled from the
marginal distributions
independently actually
the shooter code in the red box defines
a coupling between the conditional
marginal distributions thus
the shoulder code in the inner box is
exactly
a coupling between the chains
given the chain xt and the peak the
vertices vt
where t is from zero to infinity
we can recover the chain y t according
to the coupling
initially set y zero is equal to
x zero in the following
for each step set all the values of
the vertices other than vt as unchanged
where ytvt is assigned according to
two different cases if gamma rating i
and gamma with a prime are equal then
ytvt example the conditioning on xt
according to the optimal coupling of
these two
marginal distributions otherwise
it is sampled from the marginal
distribution
because 13 yt is constructed according
to
the coupling between xt and yt
one can verify that if xt and vt
form a chain of gibbs sampling on
instance i
then y t is a facebook copy of
the give sampling on instance i prime
moreover in the constructing algorithm
one can verify that if gamma with high
and gamma vti prime are equal and
their assignments are also equal in of t
minus
one then y t v t is equal to
x t with t
thus the excursion log r prime
can be efficiently constructed from the
exclusion log on high
since to obtain ytyt xtyt
needs modifications only if gamma with t
and gamma with a prime are different or
their assignments
are different to realize the
modifications efficiently
we maintain the excursion work with
efficient dynamic data structures
the running time of the algorithm for
constraint
update is showing in the formula
the first factor is the total number of
modifications
the second factor is the time cost of
each modification
according to that the difference between
i and i prime
is bounded we have the first turn is
bounded
according to the double sharla's main
condition
we have the second term is also bounded
by employing efficient data structures
the time for each modification is also
funded
thus the overall times
by the product of the difference between
i and i prime
and the thumb polylog function of the
size of
v prime
in this work we formulate the dynamic
influence
problem we give a dynamic influence
algorithm
based on dynamic sampling the algorithm
is fast
on a broadcast of graphic models
the core of our algorithm is the
efficient dynamic gives sampling
hello summer future works one open
problem
is to extend our method to graphic
models
with unbounded degree another open
problem
is to apply our method to learning
rpm thank you